Hi I'm Lorraine and I'm Langston and this
is an Earth's Mightiest Show b-b-bonus!
Yeah this week Marvel Studios' Ant-Man
and The Wasp is available to watch from
the comfort of your own anthill. And the
Ant-Man himself, the hilarious Paul Rudd,
popped in to hang out with us here at
Marvel HQ. Check it out.
I'm here with the one and only Paul Rudd
from Marvel Studios' Ant-Man and The Wasp.
Hey, how's it going?
Oh it's going really well how are you?
I'm great. I want to start from the very
beginning and by the very beginning I
mean the very end. How did you find out
about the snap? Oh yeah, I knew about it
before. Before Infinity War. I
knew about it because I'm one of the
writers on the script and so I
was aware of some of the things like
that we saw in Infinity War. I feel
like I'm being let in on some government
secrets. It kind of feels like that. Yeah it's
it's a strange sensation to know these
things and know very few people in the
world know this. And I'm pretty good at
keeping it, you know, secret.
You're not like chatting up the cabbie?
No, no. Letting him know... You know I
have friends that want to know what's
gonna happen, you know, as far as like...I go "Well you I'm filming Ant-Man and The
Wasp" "Who's in it?" "What's going on?" I don't say a word. I don't say a word.
Well done. Thank you. Speaking of The
Wasp, you got to have a new co-hero. You
of course have been co-starring with
Evangeline previously also in Marvel
Studios' Ant-Man, but what was it like to
share some of that action on screen with
her. Great, great. She's so fun to work
with and she's such a she's I enjoy her
company I think she's perfect for the
role and it was really fun to get to
play these two parts and have them be
the duo that they've you know always
been and so it was very cool. Also, I have
to give you kudos because you played, I
think it's up to, four roles in this film
because of course you were Scott Lang
Mm-hmm. You are Ant-Man. Hmm. You are Giant Man.
And also now we can say you played Janet Van Dyne very briefly. Hmm. What was your
process like did you work with Michelle
Pfeiffer. I brought my own Janet. I didn't
want to ask Michelle Pfeiffer because
would have made me very uncomfortable to
just say it would it be okay if I study
you? Can I shadow you for a while? I would
have watched a lot of Grease 2, that's what I would have done. You're a
Stephanie Zinone fan? Oh yeah. Would
you have tried to incorporate at some
point in that scene climbing up on top
of a ladder straddling it and start
singing 'Cool Rider?' Obviously. But so
Py,m Laboratories. Right. Pym Technologies.
You got to play with a lot of fun tech.
Was there any tech that you really liked
this is such a cool fun thing to play
with on screen and also you got to be in
the quantum realm. Was it interesting
learning about that? Very interesting
learning about that. I find all of that
fascinating and I've talked with several
people who know a lot about quantum
mechanics. For me the coolest, the coolest
stuff, and certainly all of the tech and
everything that we had in the lab is the
practical kind of low-fi tech that
has been enlarged. Yeah. To serve a
purpose such as big knobs,
you know, amplifier knobs and paper clips.
My favorite thing, I think, my favorite
thing is not really tech, but my favorite
thing in the movie was that a lot of the
cables in the lab were held together by
giant bread ties. Right, I mean
getting to see how some of this special
effects were made were so mind-blowing.
Just watching how they have to sort of
map the cameras to follow your movement
and then make you small like when you're
running down the stairs. Mm-hmm.
At the school. Also I want to say one of
the best gifts of all time you running
down the stairs just rocking out as a
little outtake and I know with the film
coming to home release are there any
bloopers you hope are gonna make it in?
Any, any good times? It's interesting to
see blooper reels because I forget
actual scenes that we that we film that
don't make the cut and not just in this
movie in all movies and everything.
People say "oh do you ever watch
a movie and you're like oh I can't
believe that scene isn't in there?" I tend
to forget about them after I do
and so when I see them after the fact
it's always a surprisingly oh yeah I
remember oh my gosh of course I remember
this scene but bloopers especially those
things go in and out so they're fun to
watch because you know usually they're
they involve me laughing because a lot
of times I can't keep it together. Well
I'm excited to see it. Thank you so much
for talking with us. You guys be sure to
pick up Marvel Studios' Ant-Man and The
Wasp on digital now and on Blu-ray
October 16th. Thank you. Thank you.
Well alright there you have it folks, Paul Rudd
has all these secrets of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe. With great power
comes great responsibility
but we trust you Paul. Sure do. If you
enjoyed this Earth's Mightiest Show b-b-bonus, be sure to check out our full
episodes on Marvel.com, Marvel social
media and of course the official Earth's
Mightiest Show Facebook page where we
post bonuses like this one as well as
our favorite comics, behind the scenes
photos, and lots of other fun stuff that
you can only see over there. Yeah, we'll
see you over there.
I'm Lorraine. I'm Langston. This is Marvel,  your universe.